[Musique]
et donc là si vous regardez on voit des
petits machins qui sautent partout et ça
c'est des collemboles il y en a partout
entre la surface et quelques centimètres
de profondeur
et si on s'en va écouter encore froid
c'est la première de la classe
mais elle a raison c'est trop bien c'est
la pédologie tapé doh quoi au nom laisse
tomber c'est juste valentine avec ces
jeunes aux jeux lula mais pas du tout
pédologie c'est la science des sols oui
d'accord évidemment depuis presque
trente ans le sociologue des sciences
bruno latour s'étonne que la pédologie
ne soit pas reconnue comme une
discipline majeure et moi avec lui et
ouais la pédologie n'a pas la cote
même les géologues taquine leurs
confrères parce qu'ils s'intéressent à
des dépôts récente c'est ridicule mais
autant étudier la poussière sont nos
étagères je suis pas convaincu que le
nom en service à la discipline susnommé
il c'est dommage que cette science soit
le vilain petit canard de la géologie
alors qu'au fond est-ce qu'on n'est pas
tous des terriens
de toute façon c'est déjà mieux que la
sociaux ou pire l'économie non parce que
n'en déplaise à sheldon cooper la
géologie elle c'est une science c'est un
peu une veine récurrente chez les
scientifiques sous-entend que toutes les
disciplines ne se valent pas que les
maths sont la reine des sciences la
physique leurs valets et les sciences
sociales leur bouffon mais d'où ça vient
ce truc là qui a décidé un beau jour en
se levant le matin qu'il allait classes
et les sciences et est ce que c'est bien
les jeeps tout ça oui j'ose poser les
questions qui fâchent
et oui je vais probablement finir dans
une terrasse en béton
[Musique]
au 19e siècle le philosophe auguste
comte propose la première classification
rationnelle des sciences qu'il expose
dans son cours de philosophie positive
quand tu es considéré comme le premier
philosophe des sciences au sens moderne
et il a entrepris de ranger les sciences
comme on classe des espèces
littéralement il s'est vraiment inspiré
des biologistes et notamment de l'inné
et de son énorme chantier de la
systématique du vivant auguste en intime
a donc fabriqué une classification
naturel des sciences en essayant de
comprendre laquelle influencé laquelle
et comment et voici son chef-d'oeuvre
on y retrouve dans l'ordre les maths
l'astronomie la physique la chimie la
biologie et enfin la sociologie plus
tard il ajoutera même la morale tout
temps
ces disciplines sont rangées de la plus
générale ou universel à la plus
particulière de l'objet d'études le plus
simple comme mon triangle baignoire qui
fuit aux plus complexes comme le succès
improbable décroche dans ce schéma
chaque science dépend de la précédente
et sert de fondement à la suivante un
bilboquet est un ver de terre sont tous
les deux soumis aux lois des maths de la
physique et de la chimie mais le lombric
va en plus se conformer aux lois de la
biologie et vous savez que les petits
spaghetti que les vers de terre rejet de
leur cul ça s'appelle des tueries kull
non vous allez me dire ah mais ouais je
reconnais cette pyramide c'est là dessus
que ça pue nos bonnes blagues de
scientifiques avec les maths les plus
mieux et là sociaux kaka mes études pour
compte c'est l inverse les matons juste
le mérite d'être arrivé à maturité en
premier il dit qu elles sont positives
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'elle
serait la reine des sciences selon ses
propres mots un berceau ne saurait être
un trône c'est qu'ils causent bien le
bougre
ce fameux tron est au contraire occupé
par la sociologie la science n'a plus
nobles à ses yeux parce qu'elle nous
permet de nous comprendre nous mêmes
tout société que nous sommes
c'est d'ailleurs un des pères de la
sociologie il s'est levé un matin il
s'est dit j'ai rien à faire il pleut à
et je vais ranger les sciences et puis
après je vends créé une petite nouvelle
rsa ça m'occupera mais s'il fait tout ça
c'est pas pour pimp et son escalier
parce qu'il avait vu ça sur thoune
terrestre compte n'est pas décorateur
d'intérieur il est utopiste pour lui les
sciences ne sont pas une fin en soi
c'est un moyen de réorganiser la société
d'où l'importance qu'il accorde à la
sociologie à la morale parce que auguste
escompte un nouvel ordre social
politique et morale
et puis faut dire qu'il a vécu dans un
climat de légère instabilité politique
il est né après la révolution il a connu
un premier empire avec un dictateur qui
se prenait pour césar 2.0 une
restauration c'est important de se
sustenter une révolution de juillet re
une monarchie une insurrection du
deuxième
bic un coup d'état et un deuxième en pis
tu m'étonnes qu'ils voulaient redémarrer
le système il était plus instable que
windows millenium
après avoir rangé les sciences et en
avoir à moitié créer une nouvelle au
passage notre gus commençait un peu à
s'ennuyer à nouveau alors il a allumé la
télé il à l'arrivée devant le jour du
seigneur il s'est dit mais voilà je vais
créer une religion
c'était donc le deuxième volet de son
plan machiavélique pour une nouvelle
société
c'est ainsi qu'il fonde la religion de
l'humanité dans les années 1850 religion
qui s'appuie notamment sur sa hiérarchie
des sciences sauf que ce qui est marrant
c'est qu'il était apte et c'est une
religion de laïcs ou huit ça existe en
gros c'est une espèce d'humanisme et de
culte du progrès matinée d'une morale
basée sur l'altruisme mots qu'il a aussi
inventé pour l'occasion ça faisait
longtemps qu'il n'avait pas créé un truc
en résumé louer des cartes et soyez joue
un peu comme les et éthicien
bienveillant en fait il est allé jusqu'à
créer un calendrier avec un thème par
mois et un patron par jour de moïse à
pythagore en passant par cyrus leonidas
pas les chocolats raphaël montgolfier
compter les crayons voltaire bouddha
mozart confucius qm henri iv louis xix
buffon poussins michael jackson où
platon hier l'intrus là je crois il ya
plein de trucs un peu obscur dans ça
c'est que religion j'ai vraiment pas
tout compris mais je crois qu'au moment
de ce tournage là présentement on serait
dans le mois qui célèbre le fétichisme
le succès de sa période rose a été
plutôt mitigé
ces femmes non une polo les uns après
les autres y compris ses plus éminents
poteau comme le philosophe et économiste
britannique john stuart mill ou litres
et le mec du dico cellou bas ont même
écrit qu'il y avait un bon compte
le philosophe des débuts et à un mauvais
comptes l'autoproclamé grand prêtre de
l'humanité est comme chacun sait les
bons comptes font les bons amis
du coup le mauvais comptes avait plus
trop d'amis mais à l'époque sa religion
a quand même pas mal essaimé dans le
monde notamment en angleterre aux états
unis en inde et en amérique latine et
d'ailleurs c'est à ce grand gaillard que
le brésil doit sa devise ordem et
progresso l'ordre et le progrès deux
piliers du positivisme
aujourd'hui ce mouvement c'est presque
étant même s'il subsiste un petit noyau
de croyants au brésil à elle nous fait
voyager cette hiérarchie des sciences on
compte aujourd'hui quatre chapelles
positiviste dans le monde 3 au pays des
favelas ce dont une qui arbore ses
ravissantes marche et une dernière à
paris en plein coeur du marais c'est la
chapelle de l'humanité qui a été
construite par l'église positiviste
brésilienne encore elle
d'après les plans du grand prêtre c'est
un genre de temple à la gloire des
grandes figures de l'histoire à et des
sciences la chapelle est rarement
ouvertes au public mais parfois on peut
la visiter pendant les journées du
patrimoine
voilà c'était le point stéphane bern
mais on s'écarte légèrement du sujet
revenons à notre hiérarchie des sciences
même en dehors de ce cercle restreint
des adorateurs de l'humanité cette
classification a fait forte impression
sur les esprits les plus brillants de
l'époque
elle a été reprise par d'autres
philosophe et sociologue des sciences et
elle reste aujourd'hui encore le schéma
le plus populaire il suffit d'aller sur
la page wikipedia l'entrée science pour
voir par quoi elle est illustrée
mais tout ce que je vous ai présenté là
c'est un modèle je dis pas que c'est la
réalité
c'est ce qu'on va essayer de voir il
faut tester est-ce que l'observation
colle à ce ravissante escaliers des
sciences tel un vieux chewing gum de la
honte sur la semaine d'une crosse
la première question à se poser c'est
quand tu as comme âge et la de diam's et
comment peut-on vérifier la validité de
ce modèle c'est ce qu'ont fait pas mal
de chercheurs avec des résultats mitigés
et bien par exemple on peut mesurer le
degré de consensus qui transparaît dans
chaque science la dernière étude en date
remonte à 2013 les auteurs ont passé en
revue près de trente mille articles
scientifiques balayant douze disciplines
ils ont mesuré des paramètres censé
refléter le degré de consensus par
exemple le nombre de coauteurs la
longueur d'un article et le nombre de
références
en gros plus on bosse sur un consensus -
on aurait besoin de replacer le contexte
est de justifier son approche donc plus
les papiers devraient être court et y
aurait moins de références dedans c'est
l'idée générale perso je suis moyen
convaincu mais admettons mais là vous
vous dites oh là tout doux pourquoi on
s'intéresse au consensus au juste ça
sort d'où cette affaire et bien selon le
modèle du père auguste plus on étudie un
truc simple et universel comme un
triangle ou un rond et puis il y aura
consensus sur la question
au contraire plus l'objet d'études et
complexes et particuliers comme la
réception de l'esthétique des sandales
chaussettes chez les touristes d'âge mûr
pardon les touristes positif plus on
aura de résultat différent donc moi y
aura de consensus donc si ce modèle
tient la route on devrait avoir un
gradient avec un degré de consensus
supérieur en maths physique et moins
grands sciences humaines et sociales
avec un taux intermédiaire en biologie
et bah je vous le donne en mille c'est
exactement ce que les chercheurs ont
observé ici quand on part de la physique
jusqu'au sciences humaines et sociales
il ya de moins en moins de co auteur par
études les articles sont plus longs ils
sont plus écrit à la première personne
ici davantage de références et en
particulier des livres et il ne cite pas
tous les mêmes sources
alors quand matheron physique les
papiers ont plus tendance à s'appuyer
sur un socle d'études communes bref il
semblerait qu'il y ait le plus grand
consensus en maths physique et le moins
grand en sciences humaines et sociales
et effectivement c'est science là ne se
construisent pas vraiment autour d'un
consensus c'est plutôt plein de petites
écoles de pensée parfois contradictoires
comme l'a dit bourdieu le michael
jackson de la sociologie la sociologie
est une discipline très dispersées au
sens statistique du terme
ainsi s'explique qu'elle donne
l'apparence d'une discipline divisée
est plus proche de la philosophie que
les autres sciences ce qui est pratique
c'est qu'on peut même rangée laisse aux
disciplines à l'intérieur de chaque
science en bio par exemple dans cette
étude c'est la biochimie et la bio
moléculaire qui ressorte plus dur que la
zoologie la bio végétale ou l'écologie
quoi qu il en fut tout ça va plutôt dans
le sens d'une hiérarchie des sciences
comme proposé compte plutôt qu'une
opposition stricte sciences dures
sciences molles comme on entend souvent
et comme le soutiennent certains
sociologues des sciences ce serait plus
un continuum un peu comme un oeuf qu on
fait cuire il passe pas directement du
stade coq au stade mollet puis dur c'est
progressif au passage ses termes
sciences dures sciences molles ont une
forte connotation péjorative donc éviter
de les employer si vous voulez pas finir
au fond d'un étang lesté par un rocher
comme moi quand cette vidéo sort tiens
vaut mieux plutôt parler de sciences
naturelles de sciences formelle pour les
maths et de sciences humaines et
sociales
épisode 10 quant au pop up alors déjà
première question c'est quelle
discipline qui a fait cette étude c'est
des biologistes digne mais ils sont
spécialistes des biais de publications
dans les études et tous les biologistes
bon donc là typiquement pour moi à mes
yeux c'est une logique de sciences dures
entre guillemets appliqué très
froidement sur des processus qui
implique aussi enfin qui implique
surtout de l'humain en fait il ya des
conventions d'écriture en fonction des
disciplines il ya aussi le style de la
personne etc
il ya des revues qui exige détail
d'articles qui doivent pas dépasser
temps et d'autres au contraire ça fait
pas sérieux signé ton article est d'être
au corps pour plein de raisons juste
éditorial en fait juste a fait
abstraction voilà de plein de
conventions humaines et de choses comme
ça donc il ya des critères je pense
qu'on peut utiliser pourquoi pas mais il
faut beaucoup plus de finesse là dedans
tu vois la question que je pose surtout
c'est pourquoi on veut catégorisé comme
ça et surtout hiérarchiser enfin en fait
ces catégories là elles sont elles ont
une raison d'être logistique
concrètement avant il ya longtemps les
savants il savait un peu tout de plein
de domaines etc
mais avec le temps plus il ya de savoir
et plus c'est compliqué de tout
maîtriser et de tout apprendre c'est pas
possible c'est pas non plus possible de
tout étudié au même endroit donc pour
des raisons logistiques on a commencé à
séparer les lieux de savoirs et
cloisonnée un peu les disciplines mais
il ya des certaines disciplines qui sont
complètement à cheval est assez hybride
à la fin même entre donc la distinction
sciences dures et humaines par exemple
la géographie ou l'archéologie c'est des
disciplines qui ont méthodes ou des
objets d'étude qui sont extrêmement à
cheval et des fois suivant les labos
elles sont rattachées à l'ufr de 2 m ou
l'ufr de sciences du recours si je peux
me permettre de lever quelque chose il
me semble que dans cette discussion il
ya un peu d'ambiguïté sur le type de
classification qu'on recherche c'est à
dire qu on pourrait distinguer une
classification qui reposerait sur des
objets des sciences puis une
classification qui imposerait davantage
sur les méthodes et justement quand tu
parles de la distinction science
formelle sciences naturelles sciences
humaines et sociales c'est une
classification qui repose sur les objets
quand animer ce genre de classification
là tu peux admettre qu'il ya des choses
qui sont plus fondamental ça veut pas
forcément dire que les eaux
disciple et n'ont pas d'intérêt parce
qu'en fait le niveau d' explication
fondamentale et pas forcément approprié
pour tous les objets si tu veux
expliquer une crise économique partir
des particules élémentaires c'est
probablement pas une bonne idée pour
reprendre une métaphore le site a une
maison les sciences dures elles vont te
permettre de comprendre comment tiens ta
maison etc
du coup de pouvoir comprendre ses
mécanismes et donc éventuellement de
construire d'autres maisons ce qui fait
dire à certains que c'est plus utile que
par contre les sciences humaines elles
vont te permettre de comprendre cette
lettre de mamie cta retrouver au grenier
et que tu essayes de décrypter et du
coup ça dépend juste totalement de ce
qui t'intéresse à toi reconstruire une
maison ou comprendre mieux mamie c'est à
dire comprendre mieux toi qui tu es et
d'où tu viens parce que mamie c'est ton
histoire perso etc
et tu vas mieux comprendre pourquoi en
fait tu avais un malaise à chaque fois
que tu aller manger des glaces avec
mamie c'est parce qu'en fait tu t'es
rendu compte que l aller voir son amant
le vendeur de classe et ça tu l'as
compris en lisant cette lettre que
c'était vendeurs de glace mais tu voyais
bien qu'il y avait une tension qui te
mettait mal à l'aise c'est ce que je
suis parti trop loin c'est pas ça fait
remonter beaucoup de choses bah y'a un
truc aussi sur lequel j'aime bien venir
qui est sûre cette hiérarchisation sur
le côté de la reproductibilité des
expériences en fait du coup ce qui est
plutôt de l'expérimentation
le fait est que la linguistique n'est
pas une science expérimentale on ne peut
pas reproduire des expériences pas parce
que c'est une impossibilité théorie
qu'il faut c'est une impossibilité qui
est nul en fait simplement l'éthique on
peut pas enlever des gens les remettent
dans la conditions exactes de come on
come serait l'état initial et voir
comment ça évolue et leur faire plein de
fois pour confirmer par exemple que
telle évolution politique a forcément
lieu de compter le chaos que telle
évolution morphologique était d'une
telle qu on peut juste pas le faire il
ya des trucs qu'on est tenté un comment
empêcher les gens de parler pour voir
comment ce que ça donne et c est
globalement aujourd'hui ce sont des
choses qu'on peut pas faire donc on est
obligé de se baser sur ce qui existe
déjà
il me semble quand même que ce qu'il ya
derrière c'est l'idée que le niveau de
travail adéquat pour les différentes
disciplines est assez différent parce
que en gros faut publier avec le
meilleur niveau de preuves possibles
pour ta discipline et ceux meilleurs
niveaux de preuve il est très variable
d'une discipline à l'autre même d'un
champ particulier à l'autre dans une
même discipline c'est à dire que pour
étudier le français
le niveau de preuve que qu'elle tu peux
prétendre est plus élevé que pour
étudier l'un d'eux européen forcément il
y a aussi eu un manque de sensibilité de
la part du public de ses différents
niveaux de preuve comprendre que le
niveau de preuve pour certains champs de
la physique il est extraordinairement
élevé que pour même un truc relativement
banal de biologistes déjà beaucoup plus
bas et que pour l'un d'eux européen
c'est plus bas aussi c'est peut pas dire
que c'est moins bien c'est juste que tu
es un peu de philo se plaignait encore
peut pas s'empêcher il va encore couper
des patates ce soir ou en revenir au
coeur de l'article que je vous ai
présenté il faut garder en tête que
c'est jamais qu'une seule étude est que
les précédentes n'arrivait pas forcément
aux mêmes conclusions
bref on sait pas si cette histoire de
hiérarchie des sciences à la con tu es
vraiment les jeeps d'autres chercheurs
pensent au contraire pour une opposition
sciences dures sciences molles d'autres
pour une absence totale de hiérarchie
mais hiérarchie ou pas c'est pas pour
autant que la physique vaudrait mieux
que la sociologie ou la botanique moi ce
que j'en dis c'est que toutes les
sciences ont la même valeur souffre la
pédologie vide
bref tout ça pour ça on ne sait pas on
est bien avancé
au moins maintenant on a une meilleure
idée d'où viennent ces blagues de cour
de récré des scientifiques et de toute
façon je sais pas si c'est vraiment
utile de classer les sciences c'est un
peu comme si on devait classer ses
propres enfants par ordre de préférence
ou pire ses crocs par couleur ça
voudrait dire qu'on en a plusieurs pères
d'ailleurs le positivisme de comptes a
pas mal été critiqué et ses idées ont
vite été dépassé par exemple on lui a
reproché le caractère normatif de son
classement il arrange les sciences non
pas selon ce qu'elles sont mais selon ce
qu'il voudrait qu'elle soit et il le
fait pour servir son agenda politique
donc avec une idéologie derrière et va
affirmer que le politique doit être au
contraire subordonnée aux sciences y a
comme un petit soucis il
on lui reproche aussi incertain
scientisme c'est à dire que la science
est vu comme une base d'où vient
remplacer d'autres institutions par
exemple l'église par une église athée
mais perso je trouve l'intention
première plutôt louable compte voulait
rendre justice à la diversité des
sciences sans perdre de vue leur unité
il voulait lutter contre la
fragmentation des connaissances et ce
qui les tiendrai ensemble c'est leur
démarche scientifique
pour citer le philosophe et demont
goblot une fois constitué la science et
hull et cohérente malgré la diversité
des ouvriers qui l'ont construite je
propose qu'on met plutôt l'accent là
dessus qu'on fasse tout ce front
ensemble face à la pensée dogmatique
plutôt de se tirer dans les pattes
ensemble loin des cartes il soyons joue
aujourd'hui toute façon leur et au
décloisonnement des disciplines gagne
beaucoup à travailler tous ensemble
d'ailleurs il ya des concepts qui ont
ricoché d'une science à l'autre les
chercheur en écologie ont piqué des tas
de trucs aux économistes par exemple et
c'est justement ça qui rend la science
dynamique c'est comme ça que naissent
des nouveaux domaines d'études mélanger
la data science la physique la biologie
la psychologie et les shs et vous
obtenez la foule aux copies l'étude des
foules et pour s'attaquer au changement
climatique il faut bien impliqué la
physique la géologie et la biologie la
psychologie l'économie ou les sciences
sociales en outre bref nous sommes à
l'aune de l'interdisciplinarité la
transdisciplinarité la bbc bref c'est
l'instant lgbt de la discipline arrêté
et c'est tant mieux
soyons patiente ific merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo si vous l'avez aimée
n'hésitez pas à liker à la partager
sans rancune les pédologue n'hésitez pas
aussi à nous rejoindre sur le discours
du vertex pour discuter de tout ça et
retrouvez moi en direct sur ma chaîne
souich sciences de boutoir dont le lien
sera en descriptions pour débriefer cet
épisode dès qu'il sort donc
venez salut les copains je peux joindre
à vous alors en fait on a établi une
hiérarchie de qui peut rentrer ou non
dans la piscine et ça va pas être
possible
mais pourquoi c'est quoi vos critères
sont complètement combat en tout cas les
crocs c'est vraiment genre mais tout en
bas de la liste comme wayne au champ de
recherche sont pas encore ouverts une
telle interdisciplinarité désolé c'est
parce que vous croyez
un peu quand même c'est gênant